JEFF DAVIS: Welcome to the
Google Cloud Platform Education
Series.
My name is Jeff Davis,
and in this session,
we'll discuss building high
performance, scalable VM
environments on
Google Compute Engine.
We'll be doing a moderated
Q&A throughout the session,
so feel free to submit
your questions with the Ask
Your Question Here field at
the bottom of your screen.
Let's get started.
Here's our agenda.
We're going to begin
with an in-depth demo
where we build the
necessary infrastructure
to support a fairly
sophisticated application.
This will illustrate all of
the key features within GCE
and give you an
idea of how quickly
and how easily you can build
a robust, scalable high
performing infrastructure.
We'll then go ahead and talk
about the wide range of GCE
features, giving more
details on the features
that we demonstrated and talking
about some other capabilities
that may be useful
in your applications
for your particular use cases.
I'll spend a few
minutes describing
how best to find information
as you're doing research
after today's
session, and you're
exploring GCE on your own.
We'll talk about strategies
for determining how well GCE
applies to particular challenges
or particular computing
workloads that you're looking
to move into the cloud.
And as I mentioned, we'll
be doing a rolling Q&A,
so feel free to keep
those questions coming.
So let's dive into a demo.
So we're going to start
with an application run
by a company called
Betterdev.IO.
This is the bdev squared system.
It's a learning
management system
that allows employees
all around the world
to find useful tidbits
provided by other developers
and get up to speed on
the newest technologies.
You can see down here that
you can easily take a look
at existing learning paths.
This information is
pulled from a database
of plans or playlists of
modules that developers
would find interesting
on particular topics.
You can find individual
modules, so for instance, here's
a series of modules on how
to teach the new Google Cloud
Platform class, as well as
something about mantas, which
we'll look at in just a moment.
You can also look at
your learning activity
and your accomplishments
and where
you are in your performance
against various plans.
So if you click through
to one of the modules,
you can see that it's a
small micro learning nugget.
It has some text, and it
has, most importantly,
a video segment.
These modules are created
by Better Dev employees,
and they're shared with
other Better Dev employees,
and then they're put together
into learning plans or learning
paths that people can follow.
If you want to add a
new module, you simply
enter the title, so I Like
Mantas, and I'm the author,
and Mantas, mantas, mantas.
And then you can choose
to upload a video file.
What this will do is actually
upload the file to a back end
and then create a new module
record in the database.
And this module will then
be available to learners
throughout Better Dev.
You can see that the new
module has appeared here,
and if you click on
any module again,
it shows you something
about mantas, for instance.
Now, some considerations when
we are running this learning
management system--
we have Better Dev
have employees all
around the world,
and so we want them to
have a good experience.
Whether they're coming from Asia
or from Europe or from North
America, we want the
performance to be good.
Additionally, we want
the video to stream
well regardless of your network
connection or your device.
So those videos
that we upload, they
may start as 4K or
1080p videos, but we're
going to want to transcode
them into various sizes
so that we can do adaptive
streaming on the fly.
So let's take a look at the
architecture behind this,
and then we'll actually show you
how to build it from scratch.
So here's the architecture.
We have users coming
from North America,
from Europe, and from Asia.
They all hit a
single IP address,
and this IP address is actually
an intelligent load balancer.
It will direct users
to the closest set
of servers that have capacity.
So you'll notice that we
have servers in US Central,
in EMEA West, and in Asia East.
We're running
NGINX servers here,
and these servers deliver
the standard user interface
to the LMS users.
If load goes up, we want this
to actually scale and give us
multiple servers automatically.
These servers are pulling
all of the configuration
data, the user information, the
information about the learning
paths, the information
about the learning modules,
out of a Cloud SQL instance.
When you create a new
module, you upload media,
and that media goes into
Google Cloud Storage.
And as I said before, we
want to transcode that media,
so we want to actually take
the original video file,
and we want to encode it
at 480p, 720p, and 1080p.
So once you dump it
in Cloud Storage,
we have transcoding servers.
These are back end servers,
separate from the front end
servers running NGINX, and
these transcoding servers
will open up the submitted
file, transcode it
into different
versions, and store it
in a different location.
Let's take a look at how
to build this actually
in Compute Engine.
So if we switch over to my
list of VMs in Compute Engine,
you can see that I have a
single back end instance that
is currently running.
This is the server that
watches for new media files
to be submitted, automatically
grabs those files,
and transcodes them and stores
them in a Google Cloud Storage
bucket.
I also then have
front end instances,
and you can see that I've got
three front end instances.
I have one in each
of the regions.
I have Asia,
Europe, and US West,
so traffic will get directed
to each of these regions
based on where the traffic
originates and whether or not
the target region has
sufficient capacity to serve
the additional requests.
I have a network load balancer,
so if I go to the Networking
section, you can see that
there is a single load
balancer that is configured.
This load balancer
provides the IP address
that we're hitting that then
directs users to the closest
available resource.
We have Google Cloud
Storage set up,
and you can see that
we have raw media.
These are the files
that are submitted
by developers who
are creating modules
to share with their peers.
And then we have
another bucket here,
and this bucket contains
transcoded video files.
These are, for instance,
the for 480p, the 720p,
and the 1080p versions
of videos that have been
uploaded by module creators.
There's also a
Cloud SQL instance,
and this is the database
that is containing
all of the user learning
path and learning
module information.
So let's test before
we take this all apart
and try to build it
again from scratch.
Let's test the
load distribution,
the geographic
routing of traffic,
and let's test the autoscaling.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to bring up three test
machines.
I have a machine
in Asia-Pacific,
a machine in EMEA, and
a machine in the US.
I am going to s-sh into
each one of these in turn,
and I'm going to do a little
load generation on each one.
Let's see, shrink
this one over here.
So you can see that I've
got three s-sh sessions.
Make this a little bigger so
that everybody can see it.
OK.
Now, again, the site
that we're going to
is the site represented
by this IP address.
So I'm going to grab
that IP address,
and let's do something simple.
Let's use Apache Bench.
We're going to do
5,000 requests.
We're going to have one
simultaneous session,
and we're going to just
pull the home page.
And I want to take
that command, and I
want to run it in three
different locations.
I want to run it
in Asia-Pacific.
I want to run it in the US,
and I want to run it in EMEA.
Now, we also want
to see the effect
that this low generation has.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to look at our back
end service configuration,
and this will give us a nice
little chart that shows us
how traffic is getting routed.
This shows us the origination
region of the traffic,
and this shows us what
back end the traffic is
getting routed to.
So with that, what we'll do
is we'll kick off the traffic
sessions on each one of these,
and then we will go back
to back end services.
And what we should
see here-- now,
this is a graphical
representation that tells you
about the health
of your back ends
as well as the traffic that's
being directed to them.
This doesn't really
update in real time,
so I'm going to sort of
force it to refresh here.
But when we're done,
what we should see
is traffic
originating from three
different geographic
regions, and the traffic
is getting routed to servers
also in those regions.
Voila.
So you can see that
we've got requests
coming from Asia going to Asia.
We've got requests coming
from North America going
to North America.
And we've got requests coming
from Europe going to Europe.
You'll notice that we're
already actually reaching
the maximum utilization that
I've set on these instance
groups, so that really, we
don't want servers handling
more than 50
requests per second,
and this is handling 67.
This is handling 55.
So what should
also happen here is
we should see some autoscaling.
So the instance
groups will actually
add servers to deal with the
additional capacity requests.
So I'm going to refresh
my browser in hopes
that I can actually get--
you can see, for
instance, Asia has now
scaled up to three instances.
You can see that North America
and EMEA are scaling up
to four.
This says that there are
instances that are unhealthy.
This is probably just because
they're still spinning up,
and they haven't started
handling requests yet.
If we go back to Compute Engine,
and we go to Instance Groups,
you can look at the
instance groups,
and you can see that they're
scaling up currently.
So for instance,
if I look at Asia,
I can see that I'm
averaging about 20% CPU
utilization across
all of the instances,
and that there are three live
instances responding to load.
If I go to EMEA, we
should see that I'm
now actually up to four
instances handling the load,
and again, this has kept the
CPU utilization, on average,
down to around 20%.
So that's pretty cool.
What we have is a situation
where increased traffic drives
automatic scaling
of my instances,
and the traffic gets routed
to the nearest instance
group that has capacity.
You'll notice most of
the stuff from Asia
goes directly to Asia.
Occasionally, there may be
requests where the Asia cluster
is determined to not
have enough capacity,
so it automatically routes
it to the next lowest cost
network path, which in
this case would be Europe.
So that shows scaling
of the front end.
Let's take a quick look at
scaling on the back end.
So to check out scaling on the
back end, what we need to do
is we need to create several new
modules and upload new videos.
The video transcoding
will eat all of the CPU
for a back end server, so
if we do multiple uploads,
were going to need
multiple back end
servers to do the transcoding.
So the instance script that
we want to look at here
is actually the back
end group, and we're
going to look at it
by CPU utilization.
And let's add a couple
of additional modules.
Here's a demo module, and I'm
going to pick a video file
and upload that.
And I'm going to create another
module, and this will be Demo2.
And we'll pick
another video file.
And we can do one more, Demo3.
So now, what we've done is
we've uploaded three new video
files, each of which needs to
be transcoded, and you can see,
here's the first module.
If I click on this,
this will actually
take me to a learning module
that has an embedded video.
This is the raw 1080p video,
though, On the back end, what
we want to have happen is we
want the transcoding to occur.
If we look in the bucket behind
the scenes, what you'll see
is there are new-- there's the
Chapter 1, 2, and 3 videos.
And we want to have
more new transcoded
sessions appear here.
So you'll notice that this is
my back end instance group,
and you can see, now, instead
of having one instance,
there are three instances.
And you can see that the
average CPU utilization
is on the order of 80%--
75%, 80%.
And so what this has
done is, every time
I upload a new module
that contains a video,
a message goes to
the back end servers.
The back end servers kick
off the transcoding sessions.
The transcoding sessions
shoot the CPU utilization
through the roof.
Because I've set a limit on
the amount of CPU utilization
I'm comfortable taking on, when
I go above 60% CPU utilization,
it's builds up another
instance, and that then
pulls the next video for
transcoding out of the bucket.
And so this whole thing
is working for us.
Now, it looks great,
you say, Jeff, terrific.
How hard is this to build?
Were you up until
4:00 AM this morning
putting this all together?
And the answer is maybe,
but you won't have to be.
It's actually quite
straightforward.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to start with two bases.
What I've got is a back end
base and a front end base,
and these are simply standard
Debian images onto which
I have installed some software.
I could do that all
from scratch, now,
but it takes a little bit
of time to set those up.
What I'm going to
do, though, is I
am going to take each of these
preconfigured virtual machines,
and I am going to create
a base image from them.
So you can see, I don't
want to delete the boot disk
when I delete the instance.
I'm going to check each
of those to make sure
that that's the case.
So what we're going to do
then is these two base images
that are configured to work just
the way I want-- what I'm going
to do now is I'm
going to delete them,
but I will keep
their boot disks.
You always start this recipe
with a preconfigured machine
that works the way
you want it to.
Then what you can do is
create a boot disk image.
So I'm going to
create a new image,
and I'm going to call
this Demo Front End.
And you pick a source--
in this case is
an existing disk.
This is a disk that I took
off of a functioning VM.
And I'm going to
pick the FE base,
and I'm going to create
a new disk image.
Now, I'm doing this
all through the GUI.
You can just as easily do
this from the command line
or you can script it or you
can write custom management
tools that will automate this
entire process for you if you
like.
So while that's creating
the front end image,
I'm also going to
create a back end image,
and I'm going to call
this Demo Back End,
and again, it's going
to start with a disk.
And I'm going to go to
the LMS back end base,
and I get to create that image.
So when I'm done, I should
have two new boot disk
images, created from the
disks, on two functioning VM
instances.
Once we get that
up and running--
let me refresh this.
You can see that my two
images are being created.
Once I have these
images, I can then
create new VM instances
that look just
like the original development
machines that I was working on.
And that's great, but
I don't want to just
build them one at a time.
I actually want to have Google
Compute Engine automatically
create these instances
and be able to scale up
the number of instances or scale
down the number of instances
for me automatically.
So to do that, I
need to create what's
called an instance template.
So there's my first image done.
My second image is finishing up.
So I'm going to go to
Instance Templates,
and I'm going to create
a new instance template,
and we'll call this
Demo Front End Template.
And I'm going to pick a standard
machine configuration, so
one virtual CPU and 3.7
gigabytes of memory.
I'm not going to do a
clean Debian install.
Instead, I'm going to
pick a custom image,
and this is going to be
my demo front end image.
And I'm going to designate
the scopes available.
So when you boot
up a VM, you can
designate whether it has
access to a certain APIs.
We're going to go ahead
and set that and say,
you know what, I need
access to Pub/Sub.
I need access to Cloud SQL.
I need access to Compute Engine,
and I need access to storage.
So where's Compute Engine?
There we go.
So I set the scopes, and
what this is basically saying
is any time I boot
up an instance based
on this template,
I want to make sure
that it's using
this boot image, I
want to make sure it's
this machine type,
and I want to make sure that
it has access to these APIs.
So I'm going to go ahead
and create the template,
and then I need to similarly
create a back end template.
Now, the back end template
requires a little bit more
configuration.
I need to actually
grab a startup script,
so I'm going to look at one
of the existing instances,
and I am going to go
find the startup script.
So you can see here,
this is the script
that runs when the back end
instance server boots up.
So I'm going to go ahead and
create an instance template,
and this one is going
to be for the back end,
so we'll call it Demo
Back End Template.
Same machine configuration.
Again, I'm not going to
use a standard image.
I'm going to use a custom image.
It's the demo back end.
And again, I need to specify
what scopes it's using,
and it's going to be
using cloud Pub/Sub,
and it's going to be using
the Compute Engine API,
the Cloud Storage API.
And then I'm going to
specify which startup
script it runs when it boots.
And we'll create that.
So what we've done
is we took stock VMs,
and we added our applications.
And that created
newly configured VMs.
We took those VMs.
We copied their disks
and made images.
We took those images, and
now, we've made templates.
From the templates, we're
going to make instance groups.
So I'm going to create
a new instance group,
and an instance group
is a collection of VMs
that you can manage together.
And if they're
based on a template,
you can set up autoscaling and
load balancing quite easily.
So we're going to do Demo
Front End North America,
and I'm going to put these
all in the West zone,
and I'm going to use
an instance template.
This is going to be
the front end template.
And I'm going to
turn autoscaling on,
and I want autoscaling to be
based on HTTP load balancing
usage.
And I want to set a minimum
of one instance running and up
to five instances running.
So that is my--
actually, we'll come back
we'll do the load balancing
in just a second.
We'll start with CPU usage.
We'll create this
instance group.
Now, for the front
ends, remember
we had them globally
distributed,
so I'm going to create--
I'll just create one more.
And this will be
Demo Front End EMEA,
and I'm going to set
this to run in Europe.
There we go.
And again, I'm going to
use the same template,
and I'm going to
set autoscaling on.
And this is going to go from one
to five, and we'll create that.
So now I've created
two instance groups--
one for the front end
in North America, one
for the front end
in EMEA, and I need
to create one more, which
is for the back end.
So this will be Demo Back End--
we'll just call that
Demo Back End Group,
and we're going to
put that in US West.
And we're going to use the
Demo Back End Template.
We're going to set autoscaling
on based on CPU utilization,
from one to five, and
we're going to create that.
So now, what we have is
we have an instance group
for the back end, and that
runs in North America.
And we have two instance
groups for the front ends-- one
in North America
and one in EMEA.
If you look at the
VMs, what you'll see
is we have one instance
for the front end in EMEA,
one instance for the front
end in North America,
and one instance spinning
up for the back end that's
also running in North America.
So you can filter
here, and you can
see these are the three
instances that are currently
running.
Again, these are
autoscaling instance groups,
so they can go up to
five instances per,
but because there's no
load on them currently,
there's only one
running in each group.
Now, the next thing
that we need to do
is set up the load balancer.
This is the single
IP address that's
going to send
traffic intelligently
to the right back end,
depending on where
the request originates.
So in order to do that,
what we're going to do
is switch over to Networking,
and in Networking I
am going to click
Load Balancing,
and I'm going to create
a new load balancer.
Notice there are three
types of load balancers.
I'm going to pick an
HTTP load balancer.
You start by giving
it a name, so this is
going to be Demo Load Balancer.
You configure a back end
service, and to be clear,
this is a back end
load balancing service.
This is not the back end
service for my application.
So I'm going to create
the back end service,
and I'm going to call this
Demo Front End Load Balancing,
and I'm going to pick the North
American front end instance
group.
I'm going to say
if I'm at 30% CPU--
or if I'm at 80% CPU utilization
or 30 requests per second,
then consider this group of
servers to be overcapacity,
and then I'm going to do
the same thing for Europe.
And let's see-- don't need that.
And then I need to
set a health check,
and the health check is going to
be the Front End Health Check.
So now, my back end service for
the load balancer is set up.
My host path and rules,
I don't need to set.
My front end
configuration-- this
is going to be an
HTTP load balancer,
and it's going to
use ephemeral ports,
and I can go ahead then and
create the load balancer.
So while this spins
up in the background,
we're going to cross our fingers
and hope that, when we're done,
we click on the IP address
for the load balancer.
It's going to
automatically determine
which back end group of
servers to send us to.
We're going to go to that
back end group of servers,
and one of those
servers will respond.
And if we generate load,
the server instance groups
should automatically
scale for us.
So let's take a look.
So we cross our fingers
and hope that this actually
is going to work.
Here's our global load balancing
pointing at our back end
instance groups for the demo.
That's what we just created.
We click on this,
and I'll be darned.
Look at that.
We can see that this is
actually being served
by a demo front end
server, and it's
being served out of
the US West 1A zone,
and it has access to all
of the same information
that the previous incarnation
of the application
was using because it's
talking to the same SQL
instance in the background.
If I want to
generate some load--
let's say I want to generate
5,000 sessions with 50
simultaneous sessions.
I'm going to do that, and I
can do the same thing in EMEA.
And hopefully, what we'll see
is that this generates traffic
across our back end servers.
So let's go back end services.
We can see that this is
the previous back end
service that we had configured
for the original application.
This is our demo application.
If we click on this,
what we should see
is traffic going to--
again, we need to
wait for it to update,
but we do see traffic
going from being originated
in North America and in Europe.
And over time, the visualization
should get cleaned up,
and you should actually see
some of this going to Europe.
Let's take a look at the
instance groups real quick
and see how they're doing.
So we have the demo
instance groups.
They are all at one, currently.
They haven't needed
to autoscale yet,
but they will
autoscale as necessary.
So in the course of about
five to seven minutes,
we were able to
essentially replicate
the same sort of
configuration that we
started with by creating images
from good virtual machines,
taking the images and
creating instance templates,
taking the instance templates,
creating instance groups,
and then front ending that
with a network load balancer.
And that gives us
the configuration
that we talked about in
the architecture slide.
So a lot of details coming at
you real fast, but hopefully,
that gives you an idea of
the range of capabilities
and just how easy it is to
build high performing, scalable,
globally distributed
applications
on top of Compute Engine.
Let's take a step
back and make sure
that we can put all of those
individual examples in context
and look at Compute Engine's
overall functionality.
So by now, it should be
clear that Compute Engine is
a product that allows you
to run virtual machines
atop of Google's massive
infrastructure, so tons
and tons of computing cores,
of memory, of disk storage,
and of network,
globally distributed,
and a tooling and workflow
that allows you to easily spin
up one to hundreds to thousands
to tens of thousands of VMs
and coordinate their
activity, and also
intelligently route
traffic to the instances
based on your users needs.
We talked about
virtual machines.
There's a range
of machine types,
so you can go from
one CPU to 64 CPUs.
You can go from roughly
half a gig of RAM
to 416 gigabytes
of RAM, and they've
got a set of different
combinations of resources.
So they've got four
preconfigured sets
of recipes that
are standard, which
is a nice blend or balance
between CPU and memory.
They've got high CPU recipes
, where that's double the CPU
for a given amount of memory.
They have the inverse, which
is high memory instances,
and that's like double
the amount of memory
for a given amount of CPU.
They've got shared
CPUs, which are
the least expensive and
lowest performing VMs,
And then if none of these
preconfigured recipes
work for you, you can make
your own custom recipes
and, basically,
pick how much CPU
and how much memory you want.
For every VM that
you start up, you're
going to need attached
storage, and so GCE offers
standard and SSD
persistent disks.
Standard disks are
rotating magnetic media,
and SSDs are obviously
really good for random I/O
kind of operations.
Disk options, whether
they're SSD or persistent,
offer you very high
availability and durability.
Your data's is actually
spread across multiple disks,
so if a particular
device goes down,
your data does not get lost,
and you continue to have access.
Your data is encrypted
at REST, so Google
automatically encrypts the
data and manages the keys.
If you work in an
industry where you're
required to manage
your own keys,
you can also provide
your own keys
and manage the
encryption that way.
They optimize your
disk performance,
so if you get a 10
terabyte volume.
That's actually probably a bunch
of hundred gigabyte volumes,
and your data is
striped across that
so you don't have to do any
software RAID configurations.
And they have snapshots, which
allow you to easily back up
disks and make copies and then
transport that backup maybe
to other zones or other
regions to spin up instances.
Virtual machines range
from 8/10 of a cent
to $4 per instance hour.
You only get charged while
the machine is running,
and there are a number of
really customer friendly pricing
innovations.
Instances are billed
on a per minute basis,
so for instance, if you use
an instance for 11 minutes,
even if it's a $4
an hour instance,
you're only going to
pay roughly 1/6 of that.
You're only going to pay
for the 11 minutes you used.
There is a 10 minute
minimum, but you
don't pay for the whole
hour even if you only
use a fraction of an hour.
There are sustained
use discounts.
What this means is, if you use
an instance 24 hours a day,
seven days a week,
for the entire month,
you'll actually
get a 30% discount.
The more you use it, the bigger
the marginal discount becomes.
They even go so
far as to give you
what are called
inferred instances,
so this is, if you run one
instance for two weeks,
and you run another instance
for another two weeks,
they'll actually stitch
those two together
and say, oh, you ran an
instance for four weeks,
and they'll give
you the discount.
And they also have this thing
called preemptable instances,
which is--
these are instances that you
can get at a huge discount.
They're 80% less expensive, so
you only pay 20% of the price,
but Google reserves the right
to claw them back at any time.
So what that means is, if
you have a compute load,
for instance, where you
need 10 VMs running,
but you'd like 100, you can pay
for 10 regular instances and 90
preemptable instances.
And if, for some reason,
they take back 20% or 30%
of those instances,
you still have
a bunch of instances
that were running
at a vastly reduced cost.
We showed you, during the
demo, boot disk images,
and there are two
types of images.
There are public images,
and these are maintained
by Google or third parties.
And these are clean operating
system boot images--
so Debian, Core OS, Ubuntu.
There are also
premium public images,
so like Red Hat Enterprise
Linux or SQL Server
on Windows Server.
These, you have to pay
an additional licensing
fee on top of the
VM instance fees
because you're using third
party licensable software.
Generally, what
happens is you'll
start with a public
image, and then you'll
install your own software.
You'll change the
configuration, and then
you'll save that
as a custom image,
and that's what we
did in the example.
So we use our custom front end
and our custom back end images
in order to create
instant templates
and then autoscaling
instance groups.
So that is customizing
a public image.
You can also use the new
Google VM migration service.
This was just launched in
the last couple of weeks
and it allows you
to actually migrate
live running VMs from
other environments
to GCP with no downtime.
So check that out, or you
can also manually take, say,
AWS virtual machines, export
them as raw disk images,
and then tweak them and
import them into GCP
and then run those VMs now
in Google Compute Engine.
We had instance groups, and
again, an instance group
is simply a
collection of machines
that you can manage together
as opposed to individually.
So these allow you to easily
add or remove instances.
You can simply change the
size of the instance group,
and it can spin up
additional instances.
Gives you self-healing
on your instances,
so if for some reason
an instance goes down
and you have a
health check running,
the instance group can
determine that that instance is
no longer healthy.
It can shut it down, and then
bring up a replacement instance
with the same configuration.
We saw autoscaling, and this
can be based on CPU utilization.
It can be based on
requests per second
if it's HTTP load
balancing, or it
can be based on custom
Stackdriver metrics.
So you can basically see how
the machines are being used,
and once they exceed
an average utilization,
you can add
additional instances.
This also scales down, so if you
have five of those transcoding
servers, and then there's
no more transcoding to do,
after 10 minutes, it will start
backing off and shutting down
instances.
We saw load balancing.
And we built an
HTTP load balancer,
which not only distributes the
load across multiple back end
instance groups, but it
intelligently routes traffic
to the nearest or
fastest instance group
as long as it has capacity.
There's also TCP and
UDP load balancing
options available in GCE.
And then these instance groups
can be zonal or regional.
So a zonal instance
group is a set
of instances that are all in
the same sort of fault space.
That means they're all in the
same building in a data center.
It's possible that that
zone could go down,
so power could go out or a
network cable could go down.
You can choose to make those
instance groups regional
instead, and if you do
that, your instances
are spread across
multiple zones, which
makes it less likely that, if
there's an outage in one zone,
that that's going to interrupt
service to your end users.
You have a sophisticated
range of networking options
available to you in
Google Compute Engine.
It automatically creates
a network for you
when you create a project.
That network has a
variety of subnets,
and those subnets are all
routed for you automatically.
So it automatically
generates these routes
that allow all of these discrete
subnets to talk to one another.
You can also create custom
routes as necessary.
The firewall rules
are super flexible,
so basically, you can say that
instances with particular tabs
allow incoming traffic, whereas
instances without those tags
don't allow incoming traffic.
By default, there are a
half dozen firewall rules
created for you, but
you can tweak those
and add as many as you want.
You have the ability to create
VPNs so that your private IP
ranges within your
company are considered
to be part of the GCP
private address namespace,
or the routing happens
between the two of them,
so you can easily work
in an environment that
bridges your GCP networks
and your internal networks.
Again, we talked
about load balancing,
and you also have
cloud DNS, which
is GCP hosted public
facing DNS, if you
wanted to do DNS on the cloud.
In terms of managing
all this, you
saw me work primarily
with the cloud console,
so I did everything
sort of manually.
As it turns out,
all work that you
do in administering Google
Compute Engine is done
through a standard set of APIs,
and when I'm using the console,
the console is
talking to those APIs.
I could also use a command line
utility, like gcloud or gsutil.
Gcloud is for working with
Compute Engine resources.
Gsutil is for working with
Google Cloud Storage resources.
All of these basically
talk to the back end APIs.
There are third party
utilities, or you
can write your own custom
scripts or applications
to manage your
resources as well.
So the question is, given all
of these capabilities, given
the range of instance types,
given the instance groups
and load balancing and so forth,
what use cases can you tackle,
and what could you do
with Compute Engine?
Here's one example
for inspiration.
Frame Store is a
company that does
3D renderings and
video renderings,
and basically, they use
Compute Engine for excess burst
rendering capacity.
So they have a big
render farm on site,
but occasionally,
they need to have
a whole bunch more cores thrown
at a distributed rendering
process.
And so they work
with Compute Engine,
and they can spin up to 15,000
cores at the drop of a hat.
This actually allows them
to dramatically reduce
the rendering time,
and that allows
them to do a ton of
fast turnarounds.
So they can actually
be more creative
as well as hit
deadlines more easily,
and they save money doing it,
considerable amounts of money
relative to having the same
sort of capacity on site.
This is a big example
of the little example
that we did with the transcoding
on the back end of our LMS.
Now, after today, when you start
working with Compute Engine,
you may need to go find answers
to specific questions or guides
on how to perform
certain activities,
so let me give you a few
hints on where to look
for additional information.
Start with search.
Search is your best friend.
So if you start with GCP space
and your topic of instance--
or interest, so for instance,
GCP instance billing
will give you a
bunch of articles.
The top one or two
links will almost always
be directly relevant and
exactly what you want.
If you're trying to figure out
how to use the command line,
always start with
gcloud compute resource,
so gcloud compute instances,
gcloud compute instance groups,
autoscalers.
Whenever you want to manage
one of those pieces using
the command line, as
I was using the UI,
you would look for the
gcloud compute command,
and again, it will
give you what you need.
The documentation is
actually pretty good.
Typically, when
you search, you're
going to end up in some sort
of a how-to guide or a Quick
Start, but if you look
at the breadcrumbs
at the top of the article, you
can actually go up to the top
where you'll see a top
level table of contents.
And this is relatively standard
across all the products,
so once you master this
for GCE for instance,
you can use it for App Engine
or Google Cloud Storage
or whatever.
So there will be
Quick Starts, and this
is a very short exercise that
gets your hands dirty and gets
you up and running
on the technology.
There are how-to guides,
so this for instance,
would have guides on how
do you build an autoscaler,
how do you create an image,
how do you create an instance
group, how do you
create a load balancer,
and then there are deep
dives into APIs and concepts
and so forth.
A few notes on how
to best evaluate
how well Compute
Engine will serve
your needs for particular use
cases in your environment.
So the first thing
to consider is,
when you're trying to make
a decision about applying
a new technology to
business opportunities,
you want to take it seriously.
It's not hard, but have a
process and follow the process.
Typically, what we
recommend to people
is that you start by defining
some decision criteria.
What is it that you
need to know in order
to make a decision that,
yes, this technology will
work for you?
So for instance, does it scale
to meet our company's usage
needs?
Is it easy to configure?
Can our existing systems
operational professionals
get up to speed within
a couple of days?
Once you've decided what
it is you need to know,
then you figure out how to test.
So you're going to take
an existing use case,
and generally, you're going to
create a minimum viable product
that emulates either
something you're already doing
or something that
you hope to do.
And once you have
figured out how to test--
so what is that you're
going to build--
then you do some
research to figure out
exactly how to architect
that on the platform.
Then you're going to actually
go ahead and build it.
You also need to
decide who's going
to be on the team and
their key players.
You need to have
somebody who's going
to be responsible
for the architecture
of the application.
So for instance, are
you using Cloud SQL
as part of the solution?
How are you going to
do load balancing?
Where are you going
to locate servers?
You need some operations people.
These are the people who
are going to actually
be standing up the instances
and managing the configuration.
You need somebody who's going
to be responsible for program
managing and then
reporting out the results,
and then obviously,
you need somebody
in the business side of things
to help with the decision
making.
Typically, we find like
one month per use case
is a pretty good time period.
So in the first week, you do
your defining of the criteria,
you recruit your
team, and you agree
on what you're going to test.
In weeks two and three, you
define your architecture,
and you actually
perform some pre-testing
to make sure that you understand
how all the pieces work
and you're doing things right.
And then in the last week,
you actually perform the test,
consolidate the results,
and you make a decision.
Now, obviously,
this timeline will
change depending on the
complexity of your use cases
as well as the
investment that you've
put in terms of how many
people are on the team.
This could be longer or shorter,
but two to three month trial
period will give
you the opportunity
to test a couple of
different use cases
and make a really intelligent
decision about how to apply GCE
to your particular use cases.
So hopefully, that
gives you a good sense
of how to go about
evaluating Google Compute
Engine for specific use
cases in your environment.
And that's all for this session.
Thanks for joining us.
We'll be sending
you an email that
has a link to Code Lab,
which allows you to try out
on your own some of
the concepts that we
covered during the session.
We'd also love to
get your feedback,
so provide that
feedback on screen
and stay tuned for
our next session.
as